navigating stormy seas preventing future
crises when the global financial crisis
struck triggering the Great Recession
Europe was caught in a perfect storm of
overextended banks high debts and
declining competitiveness European rules
to avoid such storms had either been too
weak or had not been paid sufficient
attention to smooth sailing requires
regular maintenance and upgrades by
creating strong competitive economies
focused on growth investment and jobs we
can be prepared for all future
conditions our economies need dependable
banks which is why oversight in the euro
area has been entrusted to the European
Central Bank this is our banking union
it's also why from now on when banks
mess up its banks and their shareholders
who will have to pick up the pieces fast
countries can also run into trouble but
has a team with their for each other
that's why we've created the European
Stability Mechanism to help countries
hit by the storm get back on their feet
when everyone is in the same boat each
has to pull their weight everybody is
affected whether strong or weak
governments receive help so that they
can sort themselves out mend their
economies and repay their loans
by addressing the causes of our problems
and through constant vigilance Europe is
working to catch the wind and steer
clear of future crises so the next time
won't be ready no matter which way the
wind blows
the European economy stronger together
you